[Applause]
tonight we're actually reaching a little
further back
the reason the long now foundation
describes the long now as the last
10,000 years in the next 10,000 years
and we're building a clock to sort of
tell time for the next 10,000 years
the last 10,000 years refers to what
happened ten millennia ago when the most
radical thing that humanity did for
itself and to the planet was invent
agriculture there was a ferocious
everything changing event that changed
carrying capacity for humans that
affected carrying capacity for all the
other species that we have and that
process has been revolutionary from
decade to decade in the century to
century and millennium tool in
millennium up until this very day one of
the reasons I'm particularly interested
in this book that this couple is done
pamela ronald and role of a gun track is
that it is taking two current
revolutions the organic one and the
genetic engineering one which are
usually seen as being in opposition and
slamming them together which is exactly
the kind of thing that farmers and
growers and marketers have been doing
for 10,000 years it's figuring out new
angles farming is hard the hardest work
there is it's a very chancy profession
most people don't really go into farming
to make money they go into farming and
make food these guys I think have an
unusually realistic handle both on the
present of how food crops work and
especially on the future peas well
please welcome Pam Ann and roll
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart for that nice
introduction and Thank You Danielle and
the rest of the log now organizers for
for bringing us here and for putting on
this fabulous seminar series and thank
all of you for coming out on a Tuesday
night so we don't go out on Tuesday
nights and Davis doesn't happen so you
may think organic farmers and
geneticists represent opposite ends of
the agricultural spectrum you may even
think that we don't talk to each other
but we do and it's not that difficult
the reason is we both have the same goal
which is an ecologically based farming
system still many of our friends and
family have asked us if genetically
engineered crops are safe to eat and if
they will harm our environment and many
of our scientific colleagues have asked
us if organic agriculture can produce
enough food to feed the world's growing
population so this book is our response
to those questions and what we try to do
in the book is give the reader a better
understanding of what geneticists and
organic farmers actually do day to day
and also to distinguish between fact and
fiction on the debate on crop genetic
engineering
one of the other things that organic
farmers and genetic engineers have in
common is that they read the Whole Earth
Catalog 30 years ago and and came away
with the idea that there was an
appropriate technology for solving
problems in the world and we still carry
these that this idea as well as the book
with us today and you know I've I've
literally had this book this catalogue
since it came out and I didn't realize
that I was holding on to it so I could
get the editor to autograph it tonight
so that the place that Pam and I start
off with is a look at the problems of
conventional agriculture and when you
look at what kind of agriculture we have
now it's obvious that there are a lot of
pesticides used there are synthetic
fertilizers used and there are farming
practices that result in a lot of soil
erosion both in the US and around the
world
California is a somewhat unique state
because it keeps track of pesticide use
and you can see from this graph that
pesticide use in California hasn't
changed a great deal in the last ten
years despite the fact that there have
been a lot of efforts to reduce
pesticide use and there have been a few
changes there are some less toxic
pesticides being used and some more
toxic ones have been banned but there's
also considerably less farmland in
California than there was ten years ago
but still pesticide use continues and
the environmental problem with with
pesticides is that not only do do they
kill pests but they kill beneficial
insects they kill birds they
you know worms they kill beneficial
microbes that are on leaf surfaces and
in the soil and in California of course
we have a rigorous pesticides safety
system and pesticide applicators are
trained on how to use and apply
materials safely
although nevertheless each year there
are a thousand or so pesticide related
poisonings in California but in the rest
of the world there aren't these safety
programs here's a Peruvian potato farmer
without gloves without a respirator he's
applying pesticides it's clear that in
the rest of the world there are an
estimated three million cases of severe
pesticide poisoning that result in
300,000 deaths that outside of
California it's even a bigger problem
the other aspect of conventional
agriculture is that it depends very
heavily on synthetic fertilizers and
synthetic fertilizers have two main
problems one synthetic nitrogen is made
from natural gas and it's very energy
intensive it takes the equivalent of 30
gallons the energy equivalent of 30
gallons of gasoline to make the amount
of nitrogen it takes to plant a field of
corn in the Midwest if you look at that
globally 1% of energy in the world is
used to make synthetic nitrogen and as
far as the plants grow the plants likes
a synthetic nitrogen because it's
readily available to be taken up by the
plant
to be used to grow but the downside is
because it's so soluble it leeches out
of the field and to give you a sense of
how much leeches out the nitrogen use
efficiency for plants is about fifty
percent so fifty percent is taken up by
the plant and fifty percent goes into
groundwater or surface water or into the
air when it goes into surface water it
it causes algae to bloom and when the
algae die bacteria you break it down and
when the bacteria do this they take all
the oxygen out of the water so here is a
here's a slide of the Gulf of Mexico and
I think that's an oil platform in the
background this is a a slide of the Gulf
of Mexico where on one side you have
basically a dead zone that lacks oxygen
nothing can live there and on the other
side you have the living living Gulf of
Mexico the site at the Gulf of Mexico is
often sixty five hundred square miles
that forms each year from the
agricultural runoff from you know Iowa
and Kansas and Ohio and all those
Midwestern states but it's only one of
250 of these of these sites that are in
the US you know the Chesapeake Bay has
problems and other waterways around
around the country this is a satellite
photo of that of that dead zone that
forms and you can see the extent of it
as it comes out of the mouth of the
Mississippi
and if you think that world fertilizer
use is going down actually it's still
going up and this little blip at the at
the top of Russia that was the collapse
of the Soviet Union Russia is now using
as much fertilizer as they were and you
can see that it's not only a problem in
the u.s. it's a problem worldwide Asia
is using a tremendous amount of
synthetic fertilizers as well as the US
and Russia and Europe the third
tremendous problem that agriculture
faces is soil erosion this is a map of
the globe that shows soil erosion from
around the world and the dark orange
spots are the very degraded soil areas
because of soil erosion 30% of the
world's arable land has become
unproductive and when soil erodes you
know it just ends up in rivers and
streams and lakes and all the nutrients
and all the pesticides in the soil also
end up in rivers and streams and lakes
and if you'd like a close-up look of
what I'm sorry erosion this is farmland
in Iowa and the conventional farming
practice is is to leave the ground bare
until the crop is planted so you get a
lot of rain when the ground is bare and
it just runs off it's estimated that as
a result of erosion global global crop
land shrinks by more than 10 million
hectares each year and I've seen other
estimates that are as high as 20 million
hectares each year so it's an ongoing
and continuing problem
the recent estimate on soil erosion in
the u.s. is that 1.8 billion tons of
soil are lost from US soils each year
the number in China is 4.5 billion tons
so this
situation is actually worse in other
parts of the world than it is here so
what's the future of Agriculture if we
continue with these farming practices
what are our children going to inherit
from us what sort of situation are they
going to face in the next 50 to 80 years
well there's no if if we continue
farming the way we are now there's going
to be more polluted environments there
are gonna there's gonna be less wild
lands because we're going to need more
cropland to produce more food and
there's going to be global conflict
because if people aren't fed then it's
it's one of the group most common causes
for unrest in the world so starting from
this point of these very serious
problems Pam and I developed some
criteria for a more sustainable
agriculture and obviously we want to
provide abundant safe and nutritious
food because that's what that's what the
world needs clearly we want to reduce
harmful environmental inputs pesticides
and fertilizers we want to reduce energy
use in greenhouse gas emissions from
agriculture because of global warming
and the agricultural problems are just
as great as the global warming problem
in there
they're also tied together we want a
system that that reduces soil erosion
but also fosters soil fertility the u.s.
right now is eroding soil ten times
faster than it's being produced or made
and in China they're eroding soil 40
times faster than its being the
produce oh we need to reduce that trend
it's very important to enhance crop
genetic diversity one of the greatest
losses of of crop was in 1972 the
southern corn leaf blight where 710
million bushels of corn was lost to a
disease because the genetic diversity of
the of the corn crop was so narrow that
the the disease caused a tremendous
problem it's also critical to maintain
the economic viability of farmers and
real community because without farmers
there's just not going to be enough food
we want to protect our diversity to
provide the habitat for beneficial
insects and birds and we want to improve
the lives of the poor and malnourished
around the world one because it's our
responsibility to do so and two because
it will help reduce global conflicts so
organic agriculture started out as a
response to these sorts of problems and
until the year 2000 organic agriculture
was defied defined by a number of Silla
fires in the u.s. 44 or so and then in
the year to year 2000 the USDA came up
with National Organic Standards that
defined how organic agriculture was to
be implemented in this country and I'll
tell you right now just to get ahead of
things that genetic engineering of
plants was prohibited by the National
Organic Standards so this is my farm at
UC Davis and it it's an organic farm and
organic farming is is really based on
the idea of health health of the crop
health of the plants health of the soil
health of the farmer health of the
consumer and it's a ecologically based
farming system when one of the reasons
that organic agriculture reduces
pesticide use is because it uses
completely different strategies it
instead of using toxic materials to to
control pests organic farmers use crop
rotation they enhance beneficial insects
they use resistant varieties and they
use some naturally occurring pesticides
but overall organic agriculture uses
ninety percent fewer pesticides than
conventional systems so in this slide
you can see that we have a lot of crop
diversity in a small space and that that
helps to minimize the the impact of of
pests the other aspect of organic
agriculture that's important is that we
have another way of fertilizing aside
from soluble fertilizers this is a slide
of our compost Turner turning the
compost pile at the farm
and while presently compost is defined
by the USDA Organic Standards as as
being
a material that is turned five times in
15 days and reach reach reaches
temperatures between 130 and 170 the
point of that is mostly mostly to manage
human pathogens but compost on the farm
is intended to provide nutrients like
NPK and a lot of micronutrients but also
provide to provide organic matter for
the soil that helps reduce erosion and
provides a microorganism community that
helps to suppress diseases and other
pests the other role that organic
farmers provide in this case
particularly nitrogen for for the crops
is through the use of cover crops this
is our this is a field where we planted
vetch and bell beans last last fall and
this crop grew and through the use of
legumes which have a symbiotic
relationship with with with the
Rhizobium bacteria that's able to fix
nitrogen out of the air and bring it
into the plant when we turn this crop in
it fixes the equivalent of 150 pounds of
nitrogen per acre now that the the
two-edged sword about organic about
organic fertilization is on one hand
these organic nitrogen sources cover
crops and and compost are much less
soluble than synthetic nitrogen in fact
although that cover crop fixed 150
pounds per acre
only about 20% of that is available in
the first year because the nitrogen
needs to be broken down the organic
nitrogen needs to be broken down by
microbes in order to be made available
for plants and it's the same for the
compost so it's a two-edged sword it's
not as soluble but there's also less
nitrogen that's immediately available to
the plant so you might ask if organic
agriculture has has solved all those
problems solve the problems of erosion
and nitrogen use and pesticide use is it
enough you know is that has that solved
the problem enough that we can look to
the future and say well we just want to
use organic agriculture well there are a
few issues that make that more
challenging one is that there are some
pests diseases and stresses that are
difficult to address using organic
methods there are viruses that are very
hard to control there we have this
little pest on the farm called sim
filings which like high organic matter
environments and they eat the roots of
most crops and there it's we there
really isn't a control these days an
organic control for some violins there
are also environmental environmental
stresses like droughts and flooding and
salty soils and cold that limit yield
and suppress yield throughout the world
in different environments the other
challenge is that today about 3.5
percent of US agriculture is organic
that leaves ninety six point five
percent that needs to be changed and
based on the rate of change in the last
20 years it's going to be a it would be
a while before everyone transition to
organic and it would I'm not sure it's
going to happen soon enough the other
the other problem is that macat yields
of organic farms there have been
numerous studies comparing organic and
conventional and it's a it's actually a
challenging thing thing to do but if you
look at these studies the yield of
organic crops ranges from forty five
percent to ninety seven percent or even
more of conventional systems and as an
organic farmer and farm inspector i've
seen a lot of crop fields organic crop
fields and you know most of the time i
think that the yields are very
comparable there are some very good
organic farmers and they do a very good
job but there are two well i've also
seen some crops like organic rice where
due to the weed problems the yields are
regularly 50 to 80 percent of
conventional rice and you know that's
that's a serious crop loss there
the other issue if trends continue like
they are now is that organic food is
significantly more expensive than
conventional food and it may cause a lot
of problems for low-income consumers
both here and throughout the world if if
prices remain that that high
but even if we could fine tune organic
agriculture so it could have the same
yields as conventional agriculture
there's still a big problem and that
problem is is that the population on
earth is still going up it's estimated
by 2050 that there's going to be almost
three billion more people on earth so we
need to have an agricultural system that
essentially on the same amount of land
or even less land if it continues to be
degraded we have to produce much more
food and it's true that that if we
became all became vegetarians that a lot
of the corn and soybeans that are grown
in the US could be used for other
purposes but it's disconcerting I guess
to me that if you look around the world
and you look at India and China for
example as they become more affluent
they want to eat more meat and it seems
like the demands on the food supply are
going to be increasing greatly in the
next 50 years but even today in in in
2008 there were food riots this year in
in Haiti there were food riots in in
Bangladesh and the UN you know views
potential food crises as something
that's going to threaten the security of
the world so
is there more land that could be farmed
this is a hillside in Ecuador that's
being farmed and as a Central Valley
California farmer I would have said that
world that's not land that you could
farm but but there you go people are
farming it and if if we without
additional yield increases maintaining
just what we eat now would would
necessitate a doubling of the world's
crop area by 2050 that land doesn't
exist we need to increase our yields on
our existing cropland one of the other
ingredients of Agriculture of course is
is water and we haven't been using water
in a very sustainable way this is a
graph that shows the fresh water
availability per head of world
population and you can see that in since
1950 we're under attack by insects since
1950 the availability of water per head
has decreased fourfold so there's less
and as the population continues to
increase there is less and less water
available in the US and around the world
there have been underground aquifers you
could call it fossil water that have
been tapped into for the past 50 or so
years and that water isn't replaced and
so the most famous one here in the u.s.
is the Ogallala Aquifer and the water
level there has this been dropping and
dropping and dropping at some point it's
just not going to be available to be
used but if you look at how water is
used in the world sixty seven percent of
it is used in agriculture and so there's
not there's not much more
that we're going to be able to access to
farm more land we have to live with what
we have and it's possible that with
global warming that water is a declining
resource even though the demand for it
is going to be increasing so given the
the immensity of the challenge to
providing food for an increasing number
of people while maintaining the
integrity of the environment we need to
we need to consider the most appropriate
modern technology that's available in
order to solve some of these problems
and pam is going to talk about modern
genetic approaches to that meet our
criteria for a more sustainable
agriculture thank you thanks Raul so I
think I'll start on a a point that that
Stewart began which is looking at the
radical changes to our agricultural
system over time beginning 10,000 years
ago so the origin of modern wheat modern
rice and modern corn began estimated
about 4,000 to 12,000 BC and the
progenitors of these modern varieties
are in Turkey China and Mexico for about
another 11,000 years 12,000 years not a
lot happened until Gregor Mendel came
along and he figured out what our
ancestors were actually looking for so
the important point here is that the
seed contains all the traits that the
farmer needs such as yield drought
tolerance pest resistance disease
resistance but
until Gregor Mendel discovered the
principles of genetics it was a known
how to take advantage of scientific
information to do directed reading since
that time there's been many scientific
advances so for example in 1900 hybrid
maize production began and with vast
increases in in yields of maize there
have been other types of modern methods
such as x-ray mutation breeding which
introduces random mutations into the
genome which is the collection of genes
which has led to some valuable crops
such as grapefruit was induced by x-ray
mutagenesis and most of these well I'd
say all these advances have been
accepted by the population however in
1993 the first genetically engineered
crop was improved for commercial release
and there's been a lot of discussion
since then some people think that
genetic engineering is just the natural
next step in human domestication of crop
plants others believe that it's
completely unnatural so I want to just
go back to give you an idea of the kinds
of breeding that have occurred so the
Native Americans 8,000 years ago began
with this wild progenitor of modern
maize shown on top called teosinte so
teosinte produces about 10 to 20 seeds
per plant you have to break open the
seeds to get at the nutrition inside
with a hammer and the Native Americans
began the first breeding experiments and
that has evolved to today to this modern
hybrid corn production which estimates
to produce about a hundredfold more seed
for each plant so that means that we can
use a hundred times less land a hundred
times less water to grow the same amount
of food here's another example these are
all vegetables they're actually the same
species so it just shows you the
dramatic genetic variation that
conventional breeders have been able to
achieve and as you may know nothing that
you eat every day is found in nature
so everything we has been derived from
modern genetic improvements so none of
these things are found in in nature so I
want to just give a brief definition of
genetic engineering and precision
breeding they they and how they
different from conventional breeding so
genetic engineering precision breeding
differ in the way that only once a few
well-characterized genes are introduced
at a time so through conventional
breeding large sets of uncharacterized
genes are mixed together through
pollination and the breeder selects
those variants that behave well and his
or her hands the other major difference
and this is I think more where much of
the concern is is that with with genetic
engineering genes from any species can
be introduced so you can put a bacterial
gene into a plant species precision
breeding is has a similar results as
genetic engineering we can introduce
essentially a single gene into a plant
however that process uses pollination
and this just shows you graphically the
way we scientists think about it so the
yellow is one plant variety and the red
is another plant variety and the colors
represent all the genes in the genome
and pollination is across and on the
right is the chequered offspring so you
could see you have large sets of genes
that are mixed together in the
offsprings and the breeder will further
carry out further selections to refine
this approach genetic engineering
precision breeding takes the variety of
interest usually a locally adaptive
variety favored by farmers and
introduces us when to to a few genes so
those essentially are the differences
and I want to address the very first
criterion that was high on our lists are
genetically crop genetically engineered
crops safe to eat and safe for the
environment so here the science is in so
there's been over a billion acres of
genetically engineered crops planted we
know that at least for the crops that
have been commercialized I'm not talking
about everything in the pipeline but
those that are commercialized those that
you are eating today
and about 60% of processed foods
contains some genetically engineered
ingredients you're safe you don't need
to worry there's not been a single case
of adverse health or environmental
impacts from any genetically engineered
crops that have been grown over the last
10 or 15 years or were greater than a
billion acres there have been numerous
scientific societies that have looked at
this not only in the United States the
National Academy of Science but the
Royal Society in the United Kingdom the
the prestigious societies in India and
Mexico and China and Brazil and they
virtually all come to the same
conclusion that the crops on the market
now are safe to eat and that genetic
engineering presents similar risks as
conventional approaches of breeding any
time you develop a new variety you're
going to have some low level of risks
and there's some examples so for example
there's a celery variety that was
developed through conventional breeding
the farmers loved it because it was
highly resistant to an insect pest and
the consumers loved it because they can
buy it cheaper it tasted exactly the
same
however there were few farm workers that
developed some rashes when they were
picking the celery so there always will
be some low level of an attendant
consequences but the point here is that
it's similar but whether you use the
process of genetic engineering to
introduce genes or if you introduce
genes through conventional approaches
still it's important to remember that
every new variety has to be considered
on a case-by-case basis and we we need
to use the most appropriate technology
sometimes a genetically engineered crop
will be the most appropriate approach
for a particular problem sometimes not
so now I want to give you three examples
to give you an idea why scientists are
so excited about this technique so this
is the cotton bull Warren he's emerging
from his egg case and this little cute
little insect here is a big problem it
attacks cotton all over the world and
25% of all the insecticides used in the
world are used to control this pest
in the united states we used about 15
insecticides to control this pest half
of those are known or parts possible
carcinogens so this was a good target
for genetic engineering now there was
there has been a variety that is
resistant for this pest and it was
developed through genetic engineering by
introducing a protein called BT that is
a favorite of organic farmers so organic
farmers love this protein because it is
not toxic to humans it's not toxic to
other animals either and it's actually
very specific for this class of insects
so this has been this is one of the
first genetic lantern crops that's been
introduced and it's it's probably the
most widespread and there was also the
most study on this so we know that in
Arizona farmers were able to achieve the
same yield as same cotton yield as their
neighbors who are conventional farmers
however they use half the amount of
insecticides and in their fields they
have dramatically enhanced biodiversity
and that's easy to understand because
they're not spraying as many
insecticides so you're gonna have more
diversity of ants and beetles of how at
which which were species of these were
counted in this particular study in
India and 80% increase in yield was
observed in farmers fields and in China
within the first year or so insecticide
use fell by 156 million pounds per year
so to give you an idea of how much
insecticide is not being sprayed into
the environment that's almost equivalent
to all that pesticides that we spray in
California every year and researchers
have found that insecticide related
illnesses have dropped by 75 percent on
these farms using genetically engineered
cotton so again you think well problem
solved
but we can't simply rely on seed as Rao
all I hope made clear to you farming
practice ARS are very important and we
know that in some instances instances
such as in China
there seven years of growing genetically
engineer cotton other types of pests
appeared and this also is predictable
because the farmers quit spraying
insecticides so they're getting other
pests so there needs to develop other
types of methods organic methods such as
pheromone control of these other insects
and really we need to integrated pest
management approach to take advantage of
these new seeds that are being developed
the second story I wanted to tell you
about is papaya so plants like humans
get sick they get diseases they get
viral diseases and this is a picture of
papaya and you can see on the top these
sort of little spots and these this is a
papaya infected with papaya ringspot
virus which is a devastating disease and
most of the well virtually all the
papaya that we get in california comes
from hawaii in the 1950s the entire crop
of papaya in ohio was destroyed by
papaya ringspot virus the farmers who
are mostly quite poor farmers many from
the philippines there was no way to
combat this disease so they moved to
another island the entire production was
moved to the island of hawaii however in
1992 the virus was discovered in hawaii
by 1995 the production plummeted and we
were looking at the end of cheap papaya
in california and a lack of income for
these papaya growers but there's a hero
to this story this is Dennis Gonsalves
he's a local Hawaiian who was trained at
Cornell he was aware of this problem and
it had been predicted for many years by
plant pathologists that eventually this
virus was going to move so you're
familiar with the swine flu pandemic
these things get around so in the early
days of genetic engineering
he took a snippet of a mauve strain of
the virus and inserted it by genetic
engineering into papaya so this is
similar to human immunizations or
vaccinations against polio or smallpox
where were immunized with a little bit
of the virus this was a dramatically
effective approach this shows you a
field trial in 1995 in the center are
the genetically engineered papaya and on
the outside are the identical papaya
except lacking this snippet of viral
nucleic acids so this just shows you the
first arrow shows the introduction of
the papaya ringspot virus you can see
this dramatic reduction in yield of
papaya in 1998 when the genetically
engineered papaya was released to
farmers there was a huge increase in
production and this just shows two
graphs which is one area in Hawaii Puna
and a larger area so I think this is
important because this is a example
where genetic engineering was the most
appropriate technology to address a very
serious problem there was not an organic
approach to solve this problem nor was
there a conventional approach there's
nothing you can spray to control this
virus and so now about 90% of the papaya
is transgenic so if you get papaya for
breakfast its it's likely transgenic
papaya from Hawaii so now my third
example is rice so rice is a staple crop
for half the world's people about 20% of
our caloric intake is derived from rice
and rice growers on virtually every
continent except Antarctica
and this shows a typical meal in Mali
people cooking the rice many people get
eat rice three times a day so any
improvements we can make in rice rice
yields will have a dramatic impact
throughout the world
so most rice farmers have very small
farms and they have very little
technology so this is a field outside
Alexandria Egypt and here is a field in
Indonesia 25% of the world's rice has
grown in flood prone areas and here is
circled some
areas that are hardest hit at Bangladesh
eastern India Burma Thailand some parts
of Nepal the water rushes down from the
Himalayas and you can get flash floods
that are entirely unpredictable and if
they completely cover the rice the rice
will die in three days so rice likes
water but it doesn't like to be
completely submerged because the water
cuts off the oxygen of the gas exchange
and the sunlight so this is a major
problem especially because in this area
there's 2.2 billion rice consumers and
75 million of those consumers live on
less than a dollar a day so in India and
Bangladesh alone 4 million tons of rice
enough to feed 30 million people is lost
every year to floods so my colleague
David mcil at the International Rice
Research Institute knew of a wheat a
rice variety that had been discovered 50
years ago in eastern India that was
highly tolerant to submergence and
breeders had been very interested in
this variety but they failed to and they
tried conventional breeding to introduce
this trait into locally adapted
varieties but the farmers rejected all
the varieties that they received and it
was difficult to do the breeding because
it was considered to be a complex trait
and the varieties that that were
developed just did not satisfy the local
tastes and yield requirements so Dave
came to my lab about 15 almost 15 years
ago we had just isolated a disease
resistant gene for mice and he asked if
we would try to isolate this gene
encoding this submergence tolerance
trait that we called sub 1 and his plan
was to use that genetic information to
introduce this gene into locally adapted
varieties so we were able to isolate the
gene a couple years ago and using that
genetic information we generated in the
lab Dave McGill's team at the
International Rice Research Institute
developed some submergence tallest
varieties so this is a time-lapse
sequence that I'm going to show you
that was taken at the International Rice
Research Institute so it's four months
condensed into 40 seconds so here you
can see on the left is the sub ones
right so it's been planted and you can
see both varieties are doing quite well
but then in day 25 this terrible flood
comes and you can see after the flood
only 2 sub 1 variety is thriving the
conventional variety on the right artist
64 is having a much harder time at
recovering from this stress this is a
typical environmental stress in this
case it's flooding so we this is a field
trial and so a field trial is something
that's carried out in controlled
conditions in this case it was in the
Philippines in a controlled field
station but Dave Dave's group has great
collaborations in Bangladesh and India
and he was able to bring the seed into
farmers hands in those countries and
looked at how the seed actually
performed in farmers hands over three
years and they found that the farmers
found 3 to 5 fold increases in yield and
that's because in every one of those
years there was terrible floods it's
expected that flooding is going to be
increase due to global climate change so
I was fortunate last November to to
visit India and Bangladesh with the team
of scientists that were involved in this
project and we interviewed some of the
farmers to see
[Music]
so they speak a dialect called ERISA in
this part of India and sorry that was
Bangladesh but they speak the same
dialect in India in this eastern part of
India and so we also had this great
conversation in India and a tent so the
farmers were asking the scientists
questions the scientists were asking
them questions we had a lot of questions
for them too so this tells us that the
discoveries in the laboratory here in
the greater Bay area can be useful to
farmers clear across the other side of
the world and I want to just close to
bring you up to date - to where we are
now so this is a rabbit ops Asst it's a
very famous plant in scientific circles
it's a little weed in the mustard family
same as all those other vegetables that
I showed you and it was the first crop
genome to be sequenced so that means
that all the genes in this organism have
were decoded and there have been
dramatic advancements in plant genetics
even since 2000 when this first a rabbit
up this first plant genome sequence was
decoded so for example in 2000 when we
first got the Robert Office's genome
sequence it was estimated to take seven
years seventy million dollars and five
hundred people to do this well now it's
estimated by 2010 the same exact project
will take two to three minutes and
seventy dollars this is a huge
advancement since that time we've also
had the sequence of the rice genome and
that greatly facilitated our work in
developing submergence tolerance rice
and we now have dozens of plant genome
sequencing projects that are ongoing so
what are we gonna do with this knowledge
well it seems to me nearly inevitable
that genetic engineering will play an
increasingly important
in agriculture the question really is
not whether or not we should use genetic
engineering but more pressingly how we
should use it to what responsible
purpose agriculture needs our collective
help and all appropriate tools if we
were to feed the growing population in
an ecological manner and you the
consumers have a significant opportunity
to influence what kinds of plants are
developed and to address the key
agricultural challenges so we need to
direct our attention to where it matters
that we need to support the use of seed
and farming methods that are good for
the environment and good for the
consumers so I want to give you an
example where we can move forward with
this new knowledge so this I talked
about rice wheat and maize which are the
major staples of the human population
but the fourth one which you may not
realize the fourth staple crop is banana
in Eastern Africa 100 million people
rely on banana as a staple food source
however now there's a pandemic attacking
bananas called banana well it attacks
all varieties of banana and it's causing
complete crop loss every year it's
advancing conventional breeding is not
an option because bananas are generated
through tissue culture not through
conventional pollination so this is an
example where we hope that modern
genetic knowledge can be used to develop
resistant varieties so one idea is to
introduce a rice gene into banana and
see if that will develop resistance to
this very serious disease so I just want
to close by same pitting genetic
engineering and organic farming against
each other only prevents the
transformative changes needed on our
farms there really seems to be a
communication gap between organic and
conventional farmers and between
consumers and scientists although with
Obama in charge we're back to putting
science at the it's a place that needs
on the table the stakes are high and
closing that gap without good science
and good farming we cannot even begin to
dream about establishing an ecologically
balanced biologically based system of
farming and
ensuring food security so I'm just going
to leave you with a quote from Rachel
Carson one of the most important
environmental act activists of our time
who I think could be speaking about the
genetic approaches that we're using
today thank you
[Applause]
well I understand that there weren't any
questions about our talk so that's gonna
be it for the night know there's a few
it looks like all right I've got a
question first I was sifting through
these nice fat wad thank you one of the
things I understand is that mostly you
talked about the sort of pesticide
avoiding plants like BT corn or bt
cotton but there's also the herbicide
tolerant plants like Roundup Ready this
that and the other thing and the way I
understand it is some of the crops like
soybeans when they use the herbicide
tolerant soybeans they don't have to
plow every year if they don't plow every
year they're now getting no-till
agriculture and I my understanding is
that's good for the soil good for the
biodiversity good for other things is
that true yes that's true it's estimated
that this particular approach herbicide
tolerant crops and no-till agriculture
is the use in 2007 was equivalent to
removing six million cars Road just in
energy savings
23% of u.s. agriculture is no-till at
this point okay you're an organic farmer
do you till oh yes why
well we tell mostly to control weeds
I would say so you got your you got your
cover crop on there and it's pushing
nitrogen down into the soil and that's
terrific and now what in the spring you
you plow those under and plant the new
we would mow them down first and then
till them in yes what happens to some of
that nitrogen other stuff in the soil
when you till it it goes up into the
atmosphere right there is some loss to
the atmosphere that's right but if you
didn't tell it and it was sitting on the
surface there would be some loss to the
atmosphere as well partly there are many
organic researchers that are trying to
figure out how to do organic no-till and
a good site to look and see what's being
done is the Rodale farm they they really
worked hard on organic no-till but there
are lots of challenges aside from weeds
there are pests associated with not
tilling and and one of the interesting
things about no-till of course is that
the way they provide the way
conventional farmers provide nitrogen in
no-till is by injecting it into the soil
you know they would use essentially the
same fertilizer injector that I showed
on the screen so it's an interesting
question can you have no-till without
synthetic nitrogen because if you use
synthetic nitrogen they're still going
to be leaching and runoff from the field
now you mentioned row daily my day they
were the holy of holies of organic
agriculture what do they say well the
reviewer really loved the book but we
then entered an online chat session with
readers of organic farming magazine and
they weren't so happy that's interesting
well good for the magazine for being
ahead of the treaters for a change
usually behind
and this is classic Rodale I mean I knew
Bob Rodale back in the day and he was a
revolutionary he was you know gonna be
revolutionary every which way and this
sounds like yet another way um question
here from Ryan Brant which is where
right back there waving a hand who funds
miracle rice the good Rice's the genius
working for on crops and less developed
countries is completely different than
working on corn and soy in the United
States the large corporations cannot
make money off Bangladeshi farmers that
live on less than a dollar a day so all
that work was funded by grants from the
US Department of Agriculture we had a 15
year run of funding from the USDA thank
you very much to them and we also had
funding from USAID and the
collaborations with International Rice
Research Institute is very helpful
because they have budgets that these
international institutes are funded by
foundations so we had free rein to
develop these rice and distribute the
seed to farmers and they're being
distributed through the regular channels
in Bangladesh in India so farmers can do
what they want with them I mean I heard
some farmers say oh yeah we're giving
them to our neighbors somebody else said
no they're selling them to their
neighbors it's a question from Richard
no last name 96% of US Agriculture is
not organic
how versus the ownership of those two
groups organic versus none lots of small
organic farmers and a few big
conventional farmers or how does it play
out well there are there are a lot of
small organic farmers but but the
majority of organic food comes from a
few large organic farmers unfortunately
most of the local organic food of course
comes from smaller farmers but in a way
it depends
you define that to as farmers in Yolo
County have become the organic farmers
in Yolo County have become more
successful they farm more and more land
and they become bigger farmers and we
could view that as a good thing the the
issue of size is it's a tricky one
I was there's a certain implication that
small good big bad does that play out
well it's a little simplistic it I think
it depends a great deal on how people
are farming there's a lot of people in
the world that need to be fed and it's
challenging to make a living
farming on a small farm so it seems like
it takes some economies of scale if you
want to keep food prices down so we
actually didn't say anything about big
or small in our criteria because we feel
if we can address the criteria with any
time we develop a new genetically
engineered crop or a new farming
practice if we can address that criteria
maybe it'll be big maybe it'll be small
and that that's really what matters
there's a classic question that relates
to price right hauteur asks does organic
food have more vitamin vitamins and
minerals than non-organic food if so
does that make up for reduce yield and
increased cost what are we paying for
when we're paying for organic food
besides some sense of you know I think
being part of something wonderful and
deep and aesthetic UC Davis is a place
where a lot of nutritional research on
organic food has been done and the the
main studies have shown that there are
more antioxidants in apples in some
organic fruits and vegetables but to
compare
nutrition and foods is is really a
tricky thing to do because you're often
comparing different varieties grown in
different places on different soils so
it's it's it's a challenge to to tease
out what the nutritional differences are
I think what you when you're buying
organic produce you are definitely
contributing to reduction and fertilizer
runoff and pesticide use actually listen
this is a public good not a private good
yeah it's a public you're not going to
be there's no evidence that you're gonna
be healthier or your children are gonna
be healthier at least not yet
no weather except in the sense that the
environment is less contaminated very
yeah and if you're working on the farm
it's a much healthier place to be on an
organic farm
okay years to measure some of the
challenge begins with false there have
been adverse health environmental
impacts StarLink corn fungus toxin in
every cell and bt destroys efficacy of
one of the pesticides organic farmers
are allowed to use StarLink corn so BT
corn has many rides the BT corn set
released some were approved for human
consumption some were improved for
animal consumption so there was a mixing
so this is the other thing you can't
keep different seeds separate I mean
it's virtually impossible especially for
these big crops like corn so the the
seed processors mix some of this the
StarLink corn that was intended for
animals with corn that was intended for
tacos and it came in the taco shells and
there was a big outcry and people were
very worried it's now been approved for
human consumption there were no
incidences of human harm there was human
fight but there was economic effects you
know Taco Bell I think had to
practically shut down but there was no
incidence of human harm
so the CDC you could go on weeks for
Disease Control Center for Disease
Control there was like 20 reports of
people saying they were sick and the
Center for Disease Control is our
premier epidemiologists and they
investigated all those cases and there
was no link to StarLink I know there's a
lot of other information going around
but just trust me on this or trust
Wikipedia BT destroys efficacy of one of
the pesticides organic farmers are
allowed to use was the other part of
that question sure you know I think that
what that question must be addressing is
BT is a bacteria bacillus thuringiensis
and organic farmers apply a formula of
that that actually sprays the bacteria
out onto the field and when insects
ingest that bacteria they ingest the
toxin as well as the bacteria itself the
toxin has been taken out of that
bacteria and put into BT corn so one of
the concerns one of my concerns one of
the concerns of organic farmers is that
the extensive use of BT in genetically
engineered corn is going to result in
resistance to BT and organic farmers
won't be able to use that tool which is
a wonderful tool I mean I use it on on
broccoli you could use it on sweet corn
it's a wonderful tool for controlling a
small range of caterpillars so I think
this is a legitimate concern and it's
something that if you look at if you try
and evaluate BT corn on a case-by-case
basis there might be situations where
you say you know this isn't a tool that
we would like to use
or you might say hey this tool reduces
pesticide use by 156 million pounds so
it's it's worthwhile trying to develop
strategies to minimize resistance
development one of the interesting
things about that is that if you have a
diverse farming system so say you you're
grilling BT corn with other crops that
have the corn earworm
as a passed like tomatoes and they're
cotton if you're growing in a mixed
cropping area then there's always going
to be a population of susceptible ear
worms so the the development of
resistance might be reduced or even
eliminated because you have a mixed
population of insects so in the u.s. BT
corn isn't as widely grown as Roundup
Ready soybeans because the added expense
of the corn is not always justified in
corn growing areas it's actually mostly
used to control European corn borer and
in some areas European corn borer is a
pest and serious pests and the growers
will will will buy the BT corn and in
some areas it's not they don't buy the
BT corn so maybe I can just add to that
there is good data on bt cotton and
exactly this situation so plant
pathologists have known for more than 50
years that if you have a really great
pesticides it doesn't matter if it's
applied organically in the case of
sprayed BT or if it's applied transgenic
ly as in transgenic cotton there's a
high probability that the insects are
going to evolve resistance so this was a
concern early on so there was this
refuge planting strategy as Raul
mentioned where there's cotton that
don't contain this BT protein and Bruce
tabash Nick in Arizona has been a really
great study
and has shown there are now three cases
of where insects have evolved resistance
to BT and actually there's a fourth case
that evolved on organic farms but in
terms of transgenic there's three cases
they haven't actually caused a big
problem but in Arizona there has been no
development of resistance in insects and
and they they can correlate that the
presence of refuges and genetic
diversity with the breaking of the
resistance so it's another example where
you really need to integrate you can't
get away from good farming practices
speaking of corn and BT that I was
surprised by something I saw in your
book that you said that organic corn
such as there is out there because the
BT is on the crop not actually in the
plant that the the ear worms get into
the corn and when I buy organic corn it
probably has a nice live worm in there
well my husband's currently so no where
you buy that's it's a challenging pest
to control organically there you could
you could spray BT on it frequently you
can there's a a virus you can spray out
that also controls the worm you can put
oil into the in the in the tips of the
ears but the adults lay the egg on the
silk and the ear worm crawls into the
silk after it hatches
so you it's a small window to be able to
control that pest okay a couple of
questions as you might imagine relating
the corporation since such no both of
you are not corporate as I understand it
you used to be in the organic farming
business better not now is that right
that's true you could say that you're
not in sector and I have no have not had
funding from any corporation in 15 years
okay but you're aware that there are
some corporations in this business yes
and there are some questions on these
matters Adrien Conner asks what's your
take on GMO patenting should farmers
have the rights to recede from their
crops and Alexander roses I'm fine with
GE foods but not the big companies that
do most of the development how can we
help make open source GE when Michael
Pollan talked in this series a couple
months ago he mentioned that Monsanto
and Syngenta and DuPont and so on were
preventing research of the effects of
their seeds in the world and that this
was hurting the science and you said in
your book that there's some patenting
issues where academics like you would
develop these genes and then the
corporation's sometimes prevent them
from getting out in the world where
they're most needed so what's your read
on the corporate situation and what
should we do about it
so the first thing you can do is support
funding for public research so support
the USDA then assess and the USDA
because that's where we get this
nonprofit funding so we can work on
problems that are important first for
small growers that are not of interest
to corporations and to growers and less
developed countries and you know I
should say that corporations have their
place I was just in the United Kingdom
and a grower there said we want the
corporation's to continue to do their
research because we want their seed
because they have good seed and we want
that seed so you know there is a role
for for corporate research but I think
it's very important that the fruits of
publicly funded research are made freely
available and there's been a tremendous
amount of progress in this area just in
the last five years with the Rockefeller
Foundation and UC Davis leading the way
so that now when discoveries occur in
the university and in many land-grant
universities around the nation there was
an agreement that these genes be
publicly accessible to less developed
countries and that if corporations want
to license these genes they need to do
it on a non-exclusive basis so that it's
been really good to see
those changes another important thing
about that is that the there there
clearly are other entities that are
generating genetically engineered plants
to be used in the world and if the
opposition to genetic engineering is
completely broad broad spectrum that
it's against all kinds of genetic
engineering then we're throwing out the
potential to really improve agriculture
around the world because we dislike
corporations and one of the the funny
offshoots of so much social concern
about genetic engineering is that the
regulatory costs of bringing out a
genetically engineered crop have become
very very high and what that means is
that if a researcher in a university
develops a genetic engineered crop that
saves the banana crop that the
university itself is not going to be
able to afford to do to get through
their regulatory process without the
help of a corporation because the
expense of doing that has become so high
that only corporations can afford it is
that true in the labs in the developing
world or here or where well you know
that's another thing to mention is that
many many countries China India
Bangladesh even have their own programs
of genetically engineering crops and
they can bring out crops and China has
you know one of the things that Pam
didn't mention was that the bt cotton
that's used in china isn't monsanto bt
cotton it's chinese bt cotton that they
developed that
their own so you sure it isn't pirated
well I I think in China is spending more
on plant biotechnology than the United
States they put a huge investment and
one of the issues is they want their own
genes and the government is funding the
research and they will also fund the
release and the regulatory requirements
so it's a much more unified kind of
system until recently there really
weren't any large corporations that seed
corporations that's starting to change
they are developing a seed industry but
in the past everything was funded by the
government you know by the people for
the people you know that that said I
think that it was a mistake for the
Supreme Court to allow genes to be
patented
I can understand patenting I can
understand patenting a variety to say
this is a variety we put a lot of
investment in a lot of time in and we
want to get our money back but a variety
like a hybrid variety it's protected in
a variety of ways and I can respect that
but patenting genes just doesn't seem
like it makes sense in terms of the
public good piece of surveillance sort
of like get the philosophical sense that
the patnik genes is weird how does that
play out and the specifics of reality
well when you patent the let's say you
patent the Roundup Ready gene it allows
the corporation to protect that patent
and go after people that they think are
violating the and they get that for
about 20 years how long about 20 years
remember the Roundup Ready came out of
patent suddenly the price went down yeah
I'm good glyphosate which is the the
herbicide this used that it's yes but
you know that the the BT gene as an
example has been around for a long time
it it it seems funny to be able to
patent the BT gene whereas if you just
patented this specific variety of sweet
corn or cotton or or or PvP well that's
yeah that's a separate thing but right
there's a there's also the plant variety
Protection Act which allows plant
breeders to protect a variety that
they've they've developed but it's more
open-source so other people can use that
as as pollination stock right so in that
sense it's open source they can't sell
the same variety but they can breed from
it well farmers can breed from it
actually other other seed companies
can't because they've the materials
protected really but question from Rick
nice gesture no question can genetically
modified crops now be growing on
certified organic farms well of course
they they they cannot that's my brother
he knows answer to this
they cannot because it's not allowed by
the the National Organic Standards but
it sounds like you're saying you want
that change no but you know there's an
interesting there's an interesting
research program that's being done at
the unit at Iowa State University by
Matt Liebman and he's trying to he wants
to develop a more sustainable
agricultural system for the Midwest
right now the the rotation there is corn
soybeans or corn corn soybeans and if
you go there it's it's a corn and
soybean buy culture there's nothing else
there and so he's he's integrated
ecological farming practices like
increased crop rotation so he's
integrated a legume and a small grain
into the rotation he has added compost
and turned in cover crops and he's he's
even used some genetically engineered
soybeans and corn and in his system and
he's come up with a with a system that
not only on the corn and soybean part
out yields the conventional system but
also provides more income for the grower
over that four year rotation period and
so essentially he's he's developed a
system roughly according to the to the
criteria that we've set up here that
integrates more ecologically friendly
farming practices into a system that
uses some genetically engineered crops
and so it's it's not going to happen
within or again within organic
agriculture but it could happen within
the 96.5% of the rest of agriculture and
he's reduced pesticide use herbicide use
by seventy four percent and reduce soil
erosion so
the systems possible we're advocates
have certified sustainable we want a new
label based on our criteria certified
sustainable bring it on Adam voices a
question that I think is deep will the
acceptance of genetic engineering and
agriculture lead to the acceptance of
genetic engineering and animals and
humans is that okay that's it that's a
good question
I usually dodge that one by saying I'm a
plant biologist but it is a good
question I I do think that they're
actually independent streams with
independent issues so genetic
engineering if humans there has been
work on this for many years already it's
called gene therapy the same idea you
take a good if somebody has a particular
disease such as cystic fibrosis it's
known that the defect in the gene is
known and there have has been gene
therapy techniques to take a wild type
copy of the gene that's a functional
copy of the gene and use it as an
inhaler which is gene therapy which is
genetic engineering it's not genetic
engineering through the germline in the
sense that your children won't have that
good copy of the gene but there are a
lot of discussions about that and
there's also even discussions of well we
can't think of anything good with this
mutated cystic fibrosis gene you know
your children die by the age of 20 let's
just if we have the ability to fix it
let's just fix it and and then let's
pass it on to our offspring so I have my
students debate these questions because
they're very large ethical and moral
questions and you know I think you're
we're gonna see a lot of discussion
about that I do think that plants are a
much simpler ethically simpler system
because we've been tinkering with them
forever and everything we eat is
genetically improved so is the does it
matter if the process is genetic
engineering versus precision breeding
versus conventional breeding does the
process matter or perhaps what matters
is the trait that's in the plant and
and how do we decide whether we want
that trait or we don't want that trait
and again we you know we go to our
criteria well we want to trade if it
satisfies all those criteria just like
you could set up criteria for
sustainable farming you could set up
criteria for sustainable animal
production and if there was a
genetically engineered trait that would
fit into that criteria then it might
make sense if it's something that is
trying to maximize profit and and his is
not good for the animals then it
probably wouldn't fit into a sustainable
animal system a feeling that that in a
sense we're extrapolating in the wrong
direction is we got drew endy in the
audience here he spoken that this room
about synthetic biology a couple months
ago and I just spent a weekend with
George Church and craig Venter talking
about things they're doing with microbes
and synthetic biology and so on and from
the standpoint of stuff that's going on
there this is charmingly antique and
artisanal what you guys treated at iron
these plants endless testing and
meanwhile there's people out there
students putting together with a goal
BioBricks by the hundreds now and
building new organisms that do new stuff
now that may you know generates some
fears down the line I bet it doesn't
because it'll be like genetically
modified medicine which we already taken
vast abundance we get used to it because
it's good for us so I don't think it'll
it'll wash back and make things weird
for for you guys but I think there's
this weird habit it's like the embargo
of Cuba or something we decided that
there's something weird about
genetically engineered plants and we're
going to keep thinking that no matter
what how do you go against a cultural
tide like that well we need out war
because
the United States did not believe this
scientists there was just they did not
believe the scientific studies that our
earth was heating up they didn't even
believe it when we they saw the icebergs
melting and what's interesting in that
situation it was really the right more
the right wing but the genetic
engineering it really the same issues
where the scientists are saying look the
crops that are out there that are safe
there's an enormous potential we're
sequencing genomes there's all this
information let's use it but in this
case it's sort of more the left wing
that has this skepticism of science why
because the corporations are hard I
think that's it
I mean I have had a lot of discussions
with people and I think that the sort of
the last resistance is because well I
heard Monsanto does this I mean that
that's a really strong sentiment okay
here's the question comes up a bunch
Kevin Kelly voiced it pretty well do you
feel there's any advantage for farmers
and consumers to label GMOs if so what
should the label say about this because
I am a label reader I loved it when the
Center for Science in the Public
Interest got the food labeling because
you know I can read what is in there so
I thought a lot about genetic labels on
genetic engineering I I know what I hate
is the marketing you know when we are
kids were little there is GMO free
applesauce and it just drove me crazy
but there's there's no genetically
engineered apples GMO free olive oil
well there's no genetically engineer
Allah see it's complete marketing so
that really bothers me and I don't like
the term GMO because it's genetically
modified organism and of course
everything we eat is genetically
improved so that didn't work for me
either so what I feel would be really
nice if we could really have complete
information
so what pesticide residues are are on
this
crop that I'm buying what you know is
there BT protein in the crop I think
that would be legitimate this food
contains BT protein even that though is
a little bit confusing so if you take
genetically engineered papaya versus
organic papaya so the organic papaya is
infected with papaya ringspot virus it
has tons of viral RNA and DNA and you
take genetically engineered papaya it
has trace amounts of viral DNA so well
what do we do then do we have to label
the organic papaya as this can this is
infected with vast amounts of viral RNA
and protein but it would just scare
people because the organic papaya is
fine to eat that it's a it's a plant
virus it's not an animal virus so it's
it's pretty complicated
I mean maybe eventually we can go to
some kind of barcoding system so
everything we want to know is print it
out for us on that label we always have
to cut off the fruit we're against that
right
speaking of papayas my understanding is
that in Hawaii where they got the GE
papayas that you know keep everything
spot virus at bay but you can also get
organic papayas in Hawaii which they
plant in the middle of the GE
plantations so that the virus can't get
through all it was GE papayas to the
ship it to Japan for ten times the cost
organic does is a marketing scam to some
extent it was we actually visited Hawaii
last year and we visited some organic
growers and we visited some conventional
growers of papaya and it was the organic
grower that we one of the organic
growers we visited it was just the you
know the the nicest friendliest
open-minded hard-working guy that you
could imagine but should go out into his
his fields his orchards and you see
he's got a diverse crop system many
different fruits but you get to the
papaya and you look at it and you go
what's that yellowing up there oh well
that's the virus and and he says you
know I'll probably get a few fruit off
of that but the papaya should last you
know a number of years I'll get a few
fruit off of that this year and then
it'll die and so you can grow the fruit
but the yield on it is reduced a great
deal and it was it was just so great to
see that like oh wow this is you know
this is a real problem and the other
funny thing about about papaya
production that we saw there was that in
Hawaii where they were growing papaya
there really isn't soil they're growing
it in lava
I mean it's if you look at you go there
was no soil there it was just you know
ground-up lava and there were in fact
when they plant the papaya plants they
put a little soil in just to have
something for it to start off in so it's
a it's a different world one interesting
thing about the papaya is he cleared
fresh land thinking well you know and
that's a reasonable approach for Plant
Pathology if you plant where the virus
has not been anywhere around he didn't
think he'd get it he got it in the first
year and the problem is there's a lot of
rainforests that's being cleared to
plant papaya organically so they don't
have to use GE papaya but when you clear
the rainforests you're contributing to
global warming so all these issues are
so connected with that on the label this
organic papaya caused the death of
rainforests
last question
farmers are conservative cautious
scientists are cautious what's the
potential downside of this technology in
your domain in this industry is there
any you know you've sort of gone down a
list of things a lot of people worry
about that are actually from your
perspective not worth worrying about are
the things that are worth worrying about
in this area
there's always something to worry about
that's wake up every morning I think
well what should I worry about today so
I think even though there has not been
really any negative unintended
consequences with genetically engineered
crops and we have seen unintended
consequences with conventional crops I
think it's inevitable that we will see
some unintended consequences the
genetically engineered crops as well
even though they are they go through a
regulatory process much more rigorous
than conventional crops actually
conventional crops are not tests at all
you could breed something in your
backyard you can put it out you can feed
it to your friends you can do whatever
you want even if you're mixing wild
species and whole genomes back and forth
there are no regulations so some people
argue that's why we haven't seen any
negative effects with genetically
engineered crops other people argue that
we haven't seen any negative
consequences because do we know what
we're doing because we know what the
gene is but I think it's also highly
likely that they just haven't been
around long enough and I think that they
will catch up if we do continue along
this path with planting genetically
engineered crops there will be
unintended consequences it may be
something like I mentioned with the
celery some sort of you know an
unexpected allergy and farm workers it
may be the biggest consequences it just
doesn't doesn't work funny thing is that
is that it's unlikely that it would be
something like an allergen in the crop
because there's no
Nitori process for a conventionally bred
celery to come out onto the market but
there is an extensive regulatory and
testing period for genetically
engineered crops so I think that the
chances of something like that happening
are greatly reduced about peanuts some
people are allergic to peanuts can you
guys make us a peanut that is not an
allergenic yeah that's a big big effort
from several people several groups now
and actually Peggy limo at Berkeley and
Bob Buchanan have developed a low
allergenic wheat through genetic
engineering and people are working on
peanuts and I'm not up to date on the
progress on that you know one of the one
of the points of contention and problems
that I I can foresee with genetically
engineered crops is their compatibility
with organically grown crops and the
same crop spring grown on adjacent
fields or in the area and for that to
work it's going to take cooperation
between organic and conventional growers
and they're depending on what crop it is
and how the crop is pollinated I think
there are some real challenges there you
both have students do you have the same
students at all are they completely
separate set we have the same student
it's pretty fun sometimes students will
take my class because they know him or
they know me so they go work on his farm
so you talk about the future of food
what's the future of farmers and genetic
engineers from your standpoint well
business is booming in genetics as I
mentioned incredible advancements it's a
very very exciting time there's
discoveries rapid rates of discovery
it's it's very intellectually
stimulating and there's massive
applications so that's accelerating
full-force and of course we hope that
more and more of the discoveries will be
applied so farmers can use them who's
Michael Pollan complain bitterly if
there's not enough young farmers coming
along is that your perspective well
that's one of the thing
that we work on at the student farm is
to develop more farmers for the future
and it's it's it's challenging because
it not only takes the skills to be a
farmer it takes a significant amount of
capital to be a farmer mm-hmm and it
takes an attitude of working hard that
you have to work a lot harder as a
farmer than you do and how many are
raising vegetables and fruits in your
garden what advice do you have for these
folks No well you know raising your own
food is is really a wonderful thing
especially in San Francisco because it
saves a huge amounts of money over of
what you have to pay in the stores and
it's fresher and it's as local as you
could get so you know that's one of the
one of the solutions if you will for
making organic crops more accessible to
low income consumers is to you know
train people to farm say that there's
behind they're doing sustainable AG
right there to some extent right there
that's right yeah and should the other
GE crops they can use in their garden
that's a good question no it's really
hard
wow that's interesting no damage yet to
your children or anything yeah there's
not that many hope Garner's going to
neckli injured crops the you could get
to that Clinton so I mean I guess is you
know clean I don't your potato general
can't record anything that's they have
these terrible terminologies deregulated
which means that it's gone through this
regulatory process it's on the market
you can plant it but a lot of the crops
in the pipeline I have not they it takes
years to get to that deregulated status
so after Wendy has his way probably
people are going to be just bootlegging
and home brewing GE crops any second now
alright well you know of course for the
commercially available GE crops in the
US you'd have to sign a licensing
agreement and pay extra fees for it as
we say in propagated you could just this
gentleman and I'll give you a little bit
but you know papaya in Hawaii is another
story altogether because you can
propagate papaya from seeds so if you if
you buy a genetically engineered papaya
in the store and you grow it in your
backyard it's going to be resistant to
the the PM s V and P RSV and a couple
years ago some research well I'm not
sure who it was some people went around
Hawaii checking the papaya trees to see
the extent of genetically engineered
papaya on the islands and they found a
lot of genetically engineered papaya in
people's backyards and so the question
was well it's a genetically engineered
because of pollen drift or is a
genetically engineered because people
planted it because the trees live and no
big corporations were involved so it
didn't
legal issue that was a really people
wanted to sue the university it was the
university that was actually a really
nice story because it was funded by a
$60,000 USDA grant and it was before
there was these tremendous regulatory
costs so he just put a wire fence around
his plot and he developed this using
government funds and then he distributed
the papaya free to two farmers in the
area it was very simple back then let's
be more that thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you